كانت هذه أماكن للمعيشة ، هذا هو
المكان الذي تنام فيه القوات على الأقل في
واحدة من المناطق ، لا يوجد شيء تقريبًا لم
يتبق منه شيء قابل للإصلاح
قيل لنا إن الحفرة نفسها قد
تأثرت هنا وكانت واحدة من 10
تأثيرات حدثت هنا ، إنها حقًا
من غير العادي كيف تمكن أي شخص من
النجاة من عدم وقوع إصابات
عندما تنظر إلى الدمار
ثم تسمع كل قصص
النداءات القريبة للبطولات ، ما
نتعلمه الآن هو أنه كان هناك
تحذير متقدم إلى درجة معينة كانوا يعرفون أن
شيئًا ما كان  سيحدث أنهم
لم يعرفوا ماذا وحوالي الساعة 11:00 مساءً  في
الليل ، ذهب أولئك الذين كانوا قادرين على الذهاب إلى
المخابئ إلى المخابئ ، لكن
كان لا يزال هناك جنود خارج المواقع التي
اضطروا للبقاء فيها بسبب الوضع الأمني ، لذلك بد
الناس في الاحتماء في حوالي ال
اعة 11:00 مساءً.  ثم في 1:34 ، عندما
حدث التأثير الأول ، قال الكثير من أولئك
الذين نتحدث
معهم أنه لم يكن مثل أي شيء قد
تخيلوه من قبل بالطبع من ناحية ،
يبدأ التدريب ولكن في
نهاية اليوم  هذه
تجربة مرعبة وضع مرعب